we learned from the comments in the last
video that most of you are probably in
the bathroom
right now dude
that's the loot with your wedding soon
son she's looking at it's really really
hard to make something fake look real i
think you'll be surprised to see just
how much a corridor video changes in the
edit
a few weeks ago we went out and shot a
zombie video for the walking dead now in
reality we shot an infinite number of
videos because i would give this footage
to any different editor in here or in
the world i will get something different
back from each one somehow somewhere
there's a perfect combination of these
shots with the perfect cuts and the
perfect edits that will give a maximum
emotional punch to this video i need to
find that if you don't do a good job of
your edit you let down all the thousands
if not millions of people are going to
watch your video so i'm sitting down
here with the edit i want to show you
guys just how much this changed improved
and shifted from bouncing from adrian to
myself to sam i think you'll be
surprised to see just how much a
corridor video changes in the edit
subscribe
first a quick disclaimer you'll notice
the footage looks really flat at first
that's because it's all in its log color
state where the colors are very very
flat for color grading so right here is
the moment where we reveal the zombie to
jake it's been under a tarp in a cage
the whole time who's lying now
unleash the gate
[Music]
guilty
[Music]
zombies things that i notice as the
director when i shot this who's lying
now that line reading a little weird
unless the gate a lot of dead time
before he yells that which makes it feel
like a slow reaction the gate doesn't
have much impact when it lands on the
ground just kind of hits in the bottom
of the frame and the very next reaction
is not the zombie bursting out
explosively but the captain
just basically yelling
what just happened is the gate just got
opened the zombie needs to explode out
just needs to be a burst of energy and
we're like oh wait it's a wide shot he
comes running towards camera so there's
not a lot of actual kinetic movement on
frame all the pieces are there we can
see it it's a cohesive scene but i think
there's a lot of ways we can punch it up
we learned from the comments in the last
video that most of you are probably in
the bathroom
right now well let me say thanks for
spending your time with us here at
corridor digital today we're gonna go
around to everybody and do what's called
uh defend your amazon history now no one
knows this is coming and hashtag no
regrets
i know you recently went vegan i imagine
we're gonna see a lot of that in here uh
protein bars garden of life protein bars
hey there they are good wipes flushable
men's cleanings butt wipes those are
good to have yeah
poo pourri before you go toilet spray
that's that's just
i use that that's just common sense you
got some uh hanes striped ringer boxer
baits do you have those on today i do
hey danny how are you doing you getting
ready for yours are you getting ready
for yours i'm just looking at what i
bought it's not much
i'm just deleting all the gallons and
gallons of lube that i've ordered
my browsing history something you
haven't quite made the plunge on yet
organic miso we got white pair of boxers
here how hip are you look at this guy
look at this look at this guy
man if you showed up in that carmichael
dude with these pants on i mean wow
he'll be almost as hip as sam you're
pretty normal guy
i have many murder weapons in my amazon
history i don't want to be connected to
these murders let's see you haven't
bought anything on amazon since january
13th i don't really use amazon that much
i bought a new microphone
a microphone stand xlr cable what are
you recording bud new music young face
dude that's my rapper alter ego i gotta
make those tracks
i noticed that in your cart you got some
weight protein you going to the gym
you can't get swallowed yeah i've been
trying to get swole but
i didn't order it yet because i just
went to the grocery store a couple t's
also this is kind of interesting because
these are uh all five xl t-shirts this
was for halloween uh i was cusco from
emperor's new groove
so i had to wear like a long red
dress basically so i just ordered a
really big t-shirt that's what i've only
made two amazon orders in the last six
months but someone made this book called
milk and vine
that has a bunch of fine quotes in it
without crediting the original people
who made the vines
and it was it was a number one seller on
the amazon
bookstore
none of my vines are in it so i'm not
really mad that i wasn't credited i'm
just sort of mad that i wasn't in the
book
[Laughter]
oh these are my favorite chips they only
make them in chicago and they only sell
them in chicago so i was trying to see
if i could order them on amazon are you
able to i don't think so but
currently unavailable
all right here's my version
who's lying now
unless the gate
all right not a ton different than
adrien's but some noticeable differences
things are a little bit tighter in
general less dead space finally i tried
to add more impact to the door falling
open
boom close-up shot
everything slow motion and falling in
front of camera but my exploding shot
sorry comes out is now a close-up from
the side so that motion when it kicks in
is much more intense
now there's still some problems here
that sam noticed when he sat down oh
it's color graded now enjoy jake's line
of whose line now is completely missing
instead we get right to the action
[Music]
those lines didn't exist next to each
other in the script but sam can
manipulate it so that it seems that way
now we're just like in it
so that's much more explosive the zombie
just comes screaming out of that gate
now this is my version where i went back
and did my final cut i looked at what
sam did i liked lava's things but
there's one thing that i was missing and
that is the punctuation of the gate
being open i'm a big proponent of having
good rhythm in your edits where it's
like fast fast fast slow fast fast fast
slow and when you do that you give the
audience an idea of what's important
people love buildups more than love
payoffs nobody will tell you that but
it's true anyways here's the final
version
unless the gate
oh
[Music]
there you have it punchy intense you get
all the characters in there you know
emotionally where people are at we got
some rhythm to it we got some style to
it changing cinematography to really
emphasize the fact the gate is open and
then boom comes exploding out of the
gate they say a movie is written three
times once in the script deals with the
script of course you're actually
literally writing the movie on set it's
going to the actors and they're
interpreting it and it all shifts what
you're actually filming and then finally
in the edit because you get to rearrange
and cut and add and manipulate the
footage that you have to communicate
information to the viewer i wouldn't do
this to anyone without having to do it
to myself as well so
how often do you guys use amazon then a
lot
almost daily on there like once a week
him the story of my life by iceberg slim
[Laughter]
yeah
um so i was watching dave chappelle and
uh
he was talking about how iceberg slim
wrote a book i like to read all kinds of
books but one of my most interesting
favorite types of reads is when you read
something that's from somebody that has
a completely different opinion on
everything than you do
all right two pack of indian long skirts
this is all wendy's stuff i didn't order
these did you buy half of the supplies
for the studio on your own no i just
used to buy them on mine and then use
the corridor on who's
oh
that's the third time today you dick
let's go to the browsing history who's
looking at suits are you pregnant i
wasn't looking at suits wendy was
looking at suits is she trying to dress
you up she tried to dress you up what is
this suit she's looking at suits for me
this is a three-piece suit with a oh
look at the k-pop she's looking at suits
dude ooh classy-ass white suit
that's the loot on your wedding soon son
she's looking at suits for me son she's
trying to dress me exciting stuff ladies
and gentlemen seeing what knicks
well if you want to yeah we need lights
everyone buying okay so i got these for
my family those christmas gifts great
christmas gifts because there's a sale
soon you get the four pack i got my
parents one my brother one you bought
your parents light bulbs for a christmas
excuse dude they're not just light bulbs
man they're cute basically these light
bulbs allow you to connect through wi-fi
and control on your phone so my room
doesn't get sunlight in the morning so i
have a timer in my room that basically
sets all the lights to sunlight
temperature does this just use this
wi-fi or does it use like z-waves no
it's just wi-fi because you get to plug
it in so these are great man okay i got
the complete works of julius caesar it's
a great read really actually a good read
because this guy's life was so crazy
dude like the amount of campaigns he did
and like just the amount of problem
solving he had to do as a leader was
this it just makes you go why do i buy
that can you share that with me i can
let you borrow that one here you go guys
enjoy this okay lists which list do you
want to look at 80s downtown 80s no just
because wow you have a lot of lists
of course you have a lot of lists are
you screen capping this
these aren't wait what's in your
emergency list 1300 degrees smokeless
solid fuel tablets oh you just break it
up break it and make fire yeah okay this
is probably the most expensive thing on
the whole solar power bank
that's genius
wow
can you share this list with me chairman
i got some hiking socks working working
clothes
dude zip ties classic yeah this is all
gotta you gotta get you gotta bury your
[ __ ] somewhere
it's a standing funnel so that way she
can go to the bathroom in the wild you
just stand and pee like a guy
she's gonna have to go squat somewhere
it's pretty it's pretty clever
that's one of the things that after a
week you're thrown out of your bag then
we got this this beauty those are
amazing they just filter the most
shittiest water and make clean drinkable
water tactical pants back pants of
course a waterproof duffel bag 75 liter
waterproof good idea when you're cooking
you don't want the wind to blow out your
fire
emergency thermal blanket for two
wow waterproof backpacks 50 liters
normally meant for like front yards and
stuff
yeah spike flashlights that you just
solar power and you put around your camp
that's a good idea this is great list
i'm really impressed
uh a lanyard and a compass in one so you
you always got a direction can you share
this list with me mm-hmm okay got a
medkit this has been a learning
adventure here here's where he gets
risky though food rations
3 600 calories per bar three days
surprise it's like elvish bread it could
it has a five-year
shelf life
that is real life limbo
per bar
that's actually about the calorie count
that i'm having right now per day
waterproof matches tablets that you can
start cleaning water tack knives
leatherman bushcraft 101. yeah dude this
is really i'm i'm i'm pleasantly
surprised carmichael i feel like it's a
bit like it's about two years worth of
work you're gonna make it out of this
whole thing alive if i ever get to
ordering
i think it's a good way like a good
measure of understanding how your life
has changed look at your amazon history
or your wish list on this walking dead
video i was tasked with doing the visual
effects for it and i wanted to talk
about one of them that was a
well-planned shot that i think came out
really well and he gets stabbed and is
supposed to come sprouting out of his
chest like he got stabbed from behind
and for the actual physical shot they
actually put the stake in like i don't
know it was attached to some sort of
plate underneath his clothes the spike
is there in the camera in shot in real
life for real it's there what we could
have done is have him go like
and have like a cg spike there it's
really really hard to make something
fake look real what is easy is actually
doing it for real and then erasing it
where you don't want it there the idea
here is that we're gonna literally just
paint out the spike for the beginning of
the shot first couple frames but the
thing is i wanted to stretch that to
like seven or eight frames to really
kind of show the spike slowly emerging
paint out the steak that there's no
steak at all the steak is covering most
of the background so you track the
background and then you track in a clean
plate there should be a spike jutting
out but there's not because we only see
the steel frame of the background that i
tracked back in boom just like that i
covered it up with a piece of shoulder
what's crazy about doing effects like
this is that if you're literally look at
this underneath the microscope it's
terrible this is garbage it's not
perfectly matched up but you know what
matters not that no one's going to care
about that because it's going to be
covered up with a spike jutting out so
you don't even have a chance to really
look at it and that brings me to the
spike itself normally for something like
this you would basically just take a
still frame of the spike to animate that
going from inside of his chest to out
like revealing it behind a mask the
problem is that anytime you use a still
frame it doesn't really change much and
if it's moving it should at least change
it's a very subtle detail that your eyes
are going to pick up on but you're brian
you're brian your brian might not pick
up on that it's less about trying to add
something and more about having it there
to begin with and removing it where it's
not needed so what i actually did here
is i i rode out
the spike on every frame here up until
about this point
and so then it slowly comes shooting out
here and then at this point right here
all the background plates gone the
little animated stake gone it's now
original footage and it goes that way
for the rest of the shot here to even
this out i threw in like a little blood
splatter it's supposed to be there to
fill the void because you know you just
got stabbed the thing that sells the
shot isn't my visual effects it's the
realistic motion at which brett gets
stabbed he's like
he makes it look like he got stabbed
from behind he sells it with his motion
it's not so simple in in terms of
execution but it's simple in theory you
just you there's a spike there you have
it for the whole shot and when you're
actually getting stabbed you paint it
out and animate the stabbing coming on
and then the effect is done